[Música]
al menos 40 migrantes murieron tras un
incendio en un centro migratorio en
México decenas de personas protestaron
en Solidaridad con las víctimas la
mayoría de los fallecidos son
guatemaltecos el gobierno de este país
culpó a los traficantes de personas por
la tragedia mientras la ONU pidió una
investigación al respecto
en Estados Unidos la policía de
Nashville informó que el autor del
reciente tiroteo en una escuela local
estaba bajo cuidado médico por un
trastorno emocional y que había comprado
siete armas de fuego el presidente Joe
biden condenó lo que calificó como una
epidemia de violencia Armada contra los
niños
en Ecuador las autoridades buscan a las
decenas de personas que se encuentran
desaparecidas tras los deslizamientos de
tierra en el sur del país de acuerdo con
informes locales al menos cinco barrios
de la población de alausí fueron
sepultados
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz iniciamos en
México el gobierno elevó al menos 40 el
número de fallecidos tras un incendio
que se desató en un centro del Instituto
Nacional de Migración en Ciudad Juárez
en Solidaridad con las víctimas mortales
y sus familias decenas de personas
protestaron y dejaron flores y velas A
las afueras de las instalaciones donde
ocurrió el siniestro el secretario
general de la ONU Antonio Gutiérrez
ofreció sus condolencias y pidió una
investigación exhaustiva sobre lo
ocurrido la mayoría de los fallecidos
eran ciudadanos de Guatemala y el
gobierno de ese país responsabilizó de
la tragedia Los Traficantes de personas
conocidos Como coyotes tienen la certeza
y la seguridad a todas las familias que
haremos todo lo posible de trabajar de
la mano con el gobierno de México
primero para averiguar lo que sucedió
dar con los responsables Buscar juicio
castigo y reparación por instrucciones
del señor presidente Alejandro yamatei y
a dicionalmente a esto lograr la
identificación plena y la repatriación
de estos cuerpos en Estados Unidos Las
investigaciones en Nashville siguen tras
un tiroteo en una escuela primaria
cristiana que se saldó con la vida de
tres menores de edad y tres adultos
según la policía el atacante era un
antiguo estudiante del centro que tenía
siete armas y estaba vigilado por
problemas psiquiátricos
en las vi los investigadores tratan de
comprender Los motivos del tiroteo que
dejó a seis personas muertas en una
escuela cristiana este lunes incluidos
tres niños la policía cree que Audrey de
28 años atacó a los estudiantes al azar
pero que sí preparó a conciencia al
ataque con mapas detallados que fueron
encontrados en su domicilio se
concentran ahora en el perfil
psiquiátrico del atacante
los médicos lo atendían por un trastorno
emocional las fuerzas del orden no
sabían nada del tratamiento que estaba
recibiendo pero sus padres creían que no
debía tener armas tenían la impresión de
que no poseía ninguna después de vender
la única arma en su poder resultó que
había estado escondiendo varias de ellas
en la casa
según la policía el tirador compró
legalmente siete armas de fuego en cinco
armerías locales diferentes y uso tres
de ellas durante el ataque el presidente
Joe quien visitará el lugar de la
tragedia reiteró su llamado a prohibir
la venta de las armas de asalto una
preocupación que rechazó el líder de La
minoría del senado Johnnie
agradecemos la rápida respuesta de las
fuerzas del orden y creo que cualquier
debate sobre legislación es prematuro
hay una investigación en curso y creo
que tenemos que dejar que los hechos
salgan a la luz
en Estados Unidos circulan unas 400
millones de armas que en 2020 causaron
más de 45.000 muertes por suicidio
accidente u homicidio según los centros
para el control y la prevención de
enfermedades
[Música]
en otras noticias de Estados Unidos un
juez Federal dictaminó que el ex
vicepresidente estadounidense Mike pence
debe testificar en una investigación
sobre el asalto al Capitolio del 6 de
enero de 2021 concretamente penss deberá
responder preguntas sobre la
conversación que tuvo con Trump antes de
la toma del edificio los detalles desde
Washington con nuestro corresponsal
Cristóbal Vázquez
tuvieron una llamada el 5 de enero del
2021 día antes de la toma al Capitolio y
en esta llamada el expresidente le decía
a Mike pence que desconociera los
resultados electorales en este proceso
que era simplemente un proceso de
costumbre un proceso legal en el
congreso para reconocer los votos
electorales sin embargo
se negaba y en las llamadas que hay se
alcanza a pues grabar y a constatar que
precisamente pence se negó varias veces
a esto por eso el expresidente pues lo
llamó según
con bastante insultos precisamente por
no querer llevar a cabo este
desconocimiento electoral entonces lo
que le está pidiendo el juez del
distrito de Columbia el vicepresidente
es que testifique sobre Esa llamada pero
no necesariamente sobre lo que ocurrió
el 6 de enero de hecho el ex
vicepresidente tiene la opción de apelar
esta decisión y el equipo legal del ex
vicepresidente está en este momento
considerando que va a ser frente a esta
decisión se apelará o si efectivamente
pues eh llevará a cabo esta audiencia
con el gran Jurado del distrito de
Colombia
familiares de detenidos en el contexto
del régimen de excepción en El Salvador
salieron a las calles para seguir
exigiendo la liberación de sus
familiares arrestados y que se les
permita visitarlos en las cárceles donde
se encuentran al grito de vivos se los
llevaron vivos los queremos los
manifestantes se concentraron en San
Salvador para dirigirse a la asamblea
legislativa donde un grupo de agentes de
la unidad de mantenimiento del orden les
cortó el paso El Salvador cumplió un año
bajo el régimen de excepción que busca
combatir la violencia y que es criticado
por organizaciones que denuncian
violaciones a los Derechos Humanos
y continúan las labores de rescate en
Ecuador por los deslizamientos de tierra
en la localidad de alausí más de 10
personas han muerto y se cree que más de
60 continúan sepultadas los familiares
de los desaparecidos tienen cada vez
menos esperanza de encontrarlos en la
noche del lunes el presidente Guillermo
lasso visitó el lugar entre abucheos
Ramiro cué Barberena nos cuenta más
la ciudad ecuatoriana de lausi sigue
asolada por los deslizamientos de tierra
que se cobraron la vida de varias
personas y dejaron decenas de
desaparecidos Mientras estiman que el
número de víctimas siga aumentando las
operaciones de rescate continúan sin
embargo los familiares de los sepultados
tienen cada vez menos esperanzas Y
ahorita estoy ahí aquí quizás que me
encuentre siquiera una casa o lo que sea
este
para ver si me si me cojo algo o si no
me cojo si no ya para vivir vida de
ellos que ya no tengo esperanzas que se
encontrará en cuerpito de ellos para
verse portar Nada más estamos esperando
a mi cuñado a la hija de mi cuñado Y a
mis dos bebitas que estaban enterradas
estamos en de ayer pero no se ha podido
lograr nada entonces Esperamos que ahora
pues logremos encontrarlos para hacerles
una sepultura se merecen ellos en este
panorama hay personas que temen por su
situación y por nuevos movimientos de
tierra que tenemos miedo de que se
deslice otra vez y nos quedemos sin nada
algo igual no tenemos a dónde llevar
porque no hay aquí casas de arriendo ni
ni nada el lunes por la noche el
presidente Guillermo lasso que fue
abucheado e insultado cuando arribó a la
UCI prometió continuar con los rescates
y anunció trabajos de recuperación de
agua potable de las vías de acceso y un
complejo de viviendas de auxilio para
atender a Los afectados la lluvia es
torrenciales destruyeron carreteras
puentes y otras infraestructuras en un
contexto donde el mandatario declaró a
principios del mes el estado de
emergencia en 14 provincias por el clima
adverso y un terremoto en el norte este
de Brasil los residentes de euriticutú
en el estado de maraña o temen que las
Fuertes lluvias registradas
recientemente empeoren los
deslizamientos de tierra las
precipitaciones reportadas en esta zona
de Brasil provocaron grandes
deslizamientos y agujeros que alcanzan
los 70 metros de profundidad y 500
metros de ancho según líderes locales
los agujeros aparecieron a raíz de la
erosión de la tierra pero crecieron
debido a las lluvias poniendo en riesgo
a varias familias y viviendas
entre tanto en Colombia el presidente
Gustavo Petro anunció que convocará a
una conferencia internacional para
avanzar en el diálogo político entre la
sociedad y el gobierno venezolano el
mandatario añadió que dicha conferencia
será realizada en Bogotá posterior a la
semana santa primera de abril y contará
con invitados procedentes de Europa
América Latina y Estados Unidos
convocaré en Colombia una conferencia
internacional con el objetivo de
construir la hoja de ruta que permite el
diálogo político efectivo de la sociedad
y el gobierno venezolano hasta aquí este
Informativo en France 24 pero los
invitamos a visitar nuestra página web
triple W punto
france24.com para seguir con la
actualización de nuestras noticias
Gracias por acompañarnos continúen con
toda nuestra programación
[Música]